president Trump's former personal
attorney Michael Cohen faces sentencing
this morning
Cohen pleaded guilty to tax evasion
making illegal hush money payments on
mr. Trump's behalf during the 2016
campaign and lying to Congress Paula
Reid is at the federal courthouse in
Manhattan Paula Cohen will be allowed to
speak at his sentencing hearing this
morning
what are your sources expect him to say
that's right you won't have the chance
to address the court and he is expected
to use that opportunity to apologize
first to his family including his father
who is a Holocaust survivor and then he
is expected to denounce President Trump
and apologize to the American people for
his participation in crimes that
occurred before the election now this is
of course a man who once said he would
take a bullet for Trump but since he
said he would flip on the president
cooperate with the government which
occurred around the same time he
realized he would be indicted
since then though everything for him he
says has been about family and country
and he wants to continue to cooperate of
course the president has been publicly
bashing him and calling him a liar
Paulie
even while cooperating with the Southern
District and the Muller investigation
prosecutors are recommending prison time
for Cohen how long of a sentence is he
facing well he faces anywhere between
four and five years his lawyers have
tried to paint him as someone though who
is reformed and should be spared jail
time but prosecutors says if accused him
of being someone who tried to undermine
democracy for his own profit and are
asking for a substantial sentence now
typically judges give the benefit of
doubt to prosecutors here so we do
expect that : we'll get a jail sentence
the question today though is how long
he'll be in jail and probably will be
coming back to you later with the
developments thank you